i love you so much dude um let me ask
you i love you too man i'm glad that you
came today man
i'm glad you invited me too i really
appreciate it man i'm glad to be here
i love that you live dude you are rich
now dude
[Laughter]
you are [ __ ] i'm not
i'll tell you why i'm not yo
theo we make up about the same money
i've been i just saved
i've been saving over the years because
i i do i've been in that condo yeah
saving to be rich
look at you dude huh i was in that i bet
you got ramen made out of steak in this
i got steak i'm in front of this bastard
man it's hard to make it into that form
but
yeah yeah but um
you know this is years of saving and you
know i you know i've got animals bro
you know oh yeah you guys did have a
bunch of animals you guys still have all
those animals yeah they're upstairs in
the house
the reason why i bought this place
because you come in the podcast area
yeah
yeah no this is great man this is
awesome i'm happy for you man
i'm glad you have a place you know it's
nice to get a place probably feels more
settling
and you guys live together now we've
always lived together
okay yeah we've been there for almost
seven years you know though
yeah yeah we're like married almost five
right did you not think the last
apartment was livable for example i
thought it was
unlivable it just seemed like
it didn't seem like everybody could live
there
[Laughter]
with the animals and right humans you
mean yeah yeah animals too
very very yeah there's there was a lot
going on there
so there's something i want to share
with my my podcast um
fans listening and i want to share with
you because you're a close friend of
mine
is um when my dad died in august i
relapsed
and i just want to say that because um i
know that a lot of people um listen to
this podcast and knew that i had 17
years of sobriety
and new and you know a lot of people
asked questions about
how do i get sober or how do i get my
brother sober and um
i relapsed i i just got out of an
institution um
that it's not an institution yes it is
that's like a college bro
or an fbi that's what it looked like
holding facilities
yeah that's investigation so i have 11
days um
sober i've been going to meetings i'm i
might i'm dedicated to it again but i
just wanted to share with you out there
because um
i was super sad about um my dad passing
i couldn't handle it
and um i just had a tough two or three
months um i've had
um that's why these podcasts these new
ones since i've been out since i left
saturday out of this institution and um
and um you know you were
you're the first guy was there a girl
before me
no no there's a girl after you there is
yeah but you're the first guy
thanks man since i've been out that i'm
having on this thing because um
i just needed somebody that um that knew
was very funny
but also somebody that i want to be this
podcast is funny but i also want to be
kind of real
about [ __ ] you know what i mean i i not
everything has to be
ripping on each other and making fun of
each other's dicks or whatever
[Music]
your dick is fine bruh oh it's not that
great i know i mean
but it's like it's it's hit or miss you
know
but visually it looks like a kind of a
sweet potato
you have that sweet potato the shape is
weird huh the shape is weird no the
shape i feel like is pretty hardy
i feel like it's a little too hearty you
know
looks fully edible yeah but it's fully
edible like you'll see like yeah
sometimes i'll wake up in the morning
and it'll have like toothpicks in it
some kid will have set it by the window
yeah yeah you know like it's uh
yeah at a science fair yeah yeah yeah
yeah my dick is uh
my deck is not a fresh product you know
i mean it's been through
several wars oh it's after market right
if you look closely there's two purple
hearts on it because it's uh
survived too warm get through a lot oh
really yeah it's decorated brah i
thought it was supposed to be twins but
it's like really premature
maybe oh you think that's mike you think
that's my underdeveloped twin out of my
dick bruh
maybe i could see you bro get a little
bit of hair installed on the top of your
dick
legendary yeah but baby it works right
kind of it works very well thank you
oh that's awesome you guys are beautiful
dude yeah